in my head I thought that the whole city  would be somehow like the shrine would  all be really old and it's quite  interesting seeing that you can sort of  walk across the city and in one hour you  can sort of go from a thousand-year-old  building in a shrine through a sort of  american-style highway and shopping  malls out to sort of rivers and  mountains and by the sea there's kind of  really rapid changes of texture in the  city in the environment all the time  there's something quite beautiful about  the way certain things have been  maintained and about I guess from my  perspective this idea that time is not  as linear and progressive as we might  sort of always assume that that there's  a sense of the rebuilding of the shrines  here with this sort of repeated  rebuilding every 20 years that you're  always in one moment of time rather than  you're with something that's decaying or  growing or progressing